seven kingdoms is a single realm
made up of seven realms that once were
independent so every house in westeros
has its heraldry and
targaryens of course it's a three-headed
dragon
the two targaryen siblings are the last
of their house
daenerys targaryen the youngest daughter
of aerys targaryen
also known as the mad king she and her
older brother viserys were spirited away
after robert's rebellion he's been in
exile his whole life and he's trying to
get back
to where he feels he belongs the people
drink secret toast to your health
they cry out for their true king they
are the blood of the dragon and they
conquered westeros with dragons which
they could ride and command
dragon's eggs to near us the ages have
turned them to stone
but they will always be beautiful she
has been
on the run since she was a baby she's
never known her homeland
all she really knows about it is from
the stories her brother told her if it
weren't for
viserys then i would i would not know
anything about my heritage i wouldn't
know about
what i was the rightful heir to
basically the two of them are living
with uh with a rich
uh merchant prince he has trading
relationships with different peoples
including kyle drogo's khalasar he's the
matchmaker
she's being traded to the dothraki in
exchange for the dothraki's
military services and capturing back the
iron throne there are horse people they
live in these great
vast grass plains and they make a living
by conquering other people
for them warfare is everything she's
completely and utterly petrified of him
she's initially quite terrified of being
inducted into a tribe of people that
that her brother considers savages she
really falls in love with the dothraki
people she starts to learn their
language she starts to dress the way
they do
he misses his sister because she used to
be all his
you still slouch he's her mother and
father and brother all in one
and they would have been married in the
original targaryen history
you did not command and i wasn't
commanding you
so to see her have a life of her own and
to see her lead other people to see her
speak a language that he didn't teach
her
i think it's hard for him
the targaryen dynasty united the seven
kingdoms and lasted nearly three
centuries
it was a dynasty forged in fire sealed
in blood
and destroyed by rebellion
the targaryens are blood of the dragon
descended from the nobility of ancient
valyria a once mighty empire in the east
when the cataclysmic doom laid waste of
valyria and its people
the targaryens survived having settled
on the island fortress of dragonstone
years before
they remained there for a century until
the rise
of aegon the conqueror instead of
attempting to reclaim the eastern lands
of his
ancestors aegon sailed west for the
seven kingdoms
his sisters visenya and rainis at his
side
to keep the bloodlines pure aegon
continued the custom of his valyrian
ancestors and took
both of his sisters to wife together
they came ashore on the eastern coast of
westeros
their blazon a dragon with three heads
representing aegon and his sister wives
their words fire and blood
while their host was small in comparison
to the armies of westeros that awaited
them
aegon and his sisters had a secret
weapon
the last of the dragons
he conquered every kingdom save dawn
which eventually bowed to targaryen rule
a century later
he had the swords of his enemies melted
down by the fiery breath of his dragon
valerian the black dread
and forged into the iron throne
the capital city of king's landing was
built on the eastern coast
where aegon and his sisters first came
ashore
and aegon ordered the construction of a
royal castle on its highest hill
the red keep for 300 years the targaryen
dynasty stayed strong in the face of
rebellion
civil war and plague but the line of
dragon kings was broken
when my father ares targaryen the second
of his name
was overthrown in rebellion
my father was betrayed and slaughtered
by said jaime lannister
a member of his own kingsguard his son
and
heir my brother rhaegar perished on the
field of battle at the hands of robert
baratheon
who claimed the iron throne for himself
and so today
the only surviving members of the story
targaryen dynasty
are myself prince viserys rightful king
of the andals and ruler of the seven
kingdoms
and my sister daenerys we were spirited
away to the free cities
of the east by loyalists here we have
lived in exile ever since
dreaming of a day when we will cross the
narrow sea and take back my father's
throne
you